professor in Zoey's yes and I am water
six you are I actually have been a
professor for 16 years at MIT and taught
six you are for the last two years or
last maybe eighteen months Oh
so I assuming you guys are junior and
senior students correct actually maybe
you are junior and sophomore okay so we
are here to tell you a bit about the
super Europe class so before I tell you
about super Europe I actually want to
hear from you what is super Europe what
you guys know about super Europe anyone
come on
is here long or else I mean guys you are
here for some reason other than the
pizza okay we understand pizza is very
important but I mean you have to know
something come on
yeah so during the class you have to
present a poster at some point and also
you write a paper where else why are you
interested actually yeah Oh a new
research that's cool yeah okay what else
why did you guys come to this session
other than the free pizza research where
else do you get the class that pays you
what else okay you get shy and with your
students I'm not shy so is that this why
the communication requirement that's
correct anything else that you guys know
about the class yes okay great
no nothing wants to learn okay so let me
tell you about the class okay so super
Europe class has two components one of
them is research so like you can think
of this as two pillars to some extent
they are not very connected as much as
other classes where you have components
of other classes that all very mixed
together so in a sense that is one
component which is your research so if
you guys decide to join six you are then
you each one of you will be associated
with a faculty professor and a mentor
maybe a graduate student or postdoc and
you will be working on a research
project with within there that group of
people in their lab and that would be
the research section of this super
Europe class okay and then in addition
to the research there is the class
itself there are the lectures and the
recitations and those are more focus on
how you present your research so we are
doing the research in the lab with your
professor and mentor and then you go to
the class you hear from professors about
their research so we have every
every lecture there are people all like
professors and people from the industry
that come and tell you about their
research and then in the recitation and
some of the lectures we also talked
about how you can present your own
research whether that presentation is
through posters or through academic
papers that you write and hopefully by
the end you can submit to a workshop or
conference okay so these are the two
components now of course it is also
different from other classes at MIT in
the sense that it is a two semester
class so each semester you get six units
so in the fall semester you get the
first six unit and then you complete the
six other units in the spring for a
total of 12 units of course now those 12
units
so people when they hear six unit they
expect very lightweight class but
actually the one thing that you have to
keep in mind is that the six unit of
class are actually for the class out for
the time you spend in the lectures and
on the assignments in the class and that
is the workload is six unit of class but
then you are expected to spend ten hours
per week on your research and that would
you out paid for that's where the money
comes from okay so also keep in mind
these two things so research ten hours
per week doing your research project
with your professor and mentor and then
in class you are preparing how to write
and present your research whether in the
fall semester typically we work on the
poster in the spring we work on a paper
and that has its own set of assignment
associated those are six units but the
money is for the research and together
that is a class okay
now let me tell you a bit about the
research part so as I said each one of
you would be with working with someone
in like a professor at MIT many of you
probably are double ECS student and
perhaps you're gonna work with some
professor here in WCS actually who among
you is not in double ACS can you raise
your hand okay
yeah so we have in the class some people
from other part of the engineering
school and for you guys you also are
going to have a mentor and professor
that you are working with in your
departments and like these are some
example projects so here you see like
some people working on nanomaterials
some people working on circuits some
people working on robots many people
working on AI problems and machine
learning
it's your favorite project you get to
pick and you spend the semester on it
and at the end of each semester you
present your research so there is a
showcase where you prepare the poster
and you stand there and we invite people
from the industry we invite the faculty
and also your fellow students and
everyone is there a mingling and we have
food and it's very nice event but also
you get to tell people about your
research based on what you learned
throughout the semester so there is one
showcase at the end of the for one
showcase at the end of the spring now as
I mentioned the research part has this
$3,000 up to $3,000 if you spent 10
hours per week in the lab and $2,000 per
semester so total of six thousand
dollars and in addition to that luck
basically as I said the ten hours on the
on the research that is not like if you
can't count the time in the class and
the time on the assignment for the class
that is just an hour to research now for
students who are who are from so there
are many of the department in the
engineering school and my guess of the
people who raised their hand and said
they are not part of WCS
many of those departments are already
participating in Department in the class
but if your department is not a
participating department which means
that it did not donate money to support
their students then you can actually
either talk to your department about the
support or you can take the class just
as if it's like more formal Europe class
so you can get those credit the academic
unit but then if you if you are not from
the supporting Department and basically
we cannot pay you in the class okay so
what are the deliverables so in the fall
term as I said so the Deauville
in the class first attendance is
mandatory I'm sorry bruh it's like we
invite faculty and professors here in
double e CS we we invite people from the
industry so it's very important that you
actually show up the classes and during
the class we ask a question about the
about the lecture about the the whatever
those people have presented by the end
of the class and you enter the answer
online and that would be your attendance
so in addition to classes the class is
one hour per week and there is also one
hour of Waystation every other week and
there is about 15 minutes every other
week just checking in with your with
your TA making sure that everything is
going right and if you have problems you
can talk to your TAS if you have they
give you also feedback about your
research in journal and at the end of
the fall term you prepare a poster and
then you present that poster so now for
the spring is very very similar to the
fall except that instead of a poster now
you are working on a 10 page paper that
you finished by the end of the spring
semester and you still go and update
your poster because now you have more
results and you present your poster
again at the end of the of the spring
semester but now was full-fledged
results and understanding of your
problem and many of the people asked the
question okay so what is it great that I
get by the end of the fall term but
that's not the right way to think about
it your grade you don't really get a
grade at the end of the fall term so it
is a two term class so think about at
the end of the fall term is like you're
finishing your midterm so you can know
that whether you did well or not as well
but you can't you don't really have
grades at that point it is one class
that extend across this the fall and the
spring and you really get your grade
whatever that is at the end of the
spring term
yeah so it's one class so again think
about it exactly as at the end of the
fall is kind of like you finished with
your midterm if you drop the class at
that point you don't get any units from
the class so also one there was a
particular opportunity from a particular
donor who saw the MIT students don't get
interested enough in humanities and he
wanted to promote the connection between
humanities and engineering so he donated
for people who are to pay for projects
that combine engineering with humanities
so if you are interested in that you can
apply for those projects okay so also
you get a certificate so you get a nice
piece of paper let's say certificate and
you pass used to pull your Europe class
and we have a celebration bring cookie
and food and all that stuff we take
pictures okay so um I can stop a bit
here and ask whether you have any
questions yes okay so all so online oh
there is a sign that has proposals or
project descriptions by professors in
various departments in the Florence
School of Engineering and you can go
there and look at those proposals talk
to the P I talk to the professor and see
whether it's a good match for you and
then at the end you are asked to now
based on understanding of that project
and understanding if the what you talk
to the faculty about write a short
proposal then I'm going to do this
project that's my proposal for the work
that I'm gonna do here and I'm going to
tell you the exact deadline for them
yeah yeah that's that's possible yeah
yeah but we you can do it but we ask
that the work that you do for is a super
Europe is a new research so you can
extend your project and do the next step
with it and that would be your super
Europe back we we don't accept that oh I
did this you up before and here's my
paper here's all the work that I did now
pay me six thousand dollars that doesn't
work okay other questions bit easier for
you guys we asked the professors to
upload projects on the site and you can
go and look at those project and see
whether you are interested in any of
them talk to the professor and see
whether you have a good match but also
as your friend here said basically if
you have already a project and you have
a faculty who is interested in mentoring
you as you are doing this project that's
fine as well
it has to have intersection with
engineering but this is under the school
of engineering they are I think most of
the department in the school of the
engineering are supporting department
but yeah it doesn't have to be for six
so me as long as it has an engineering
component 18 is Mouse yeah of course
yeah it is okay but keep in mind that
basically I kind of like you have to
take responsibility so if you change
things later in the term or like after
some deadlines we are flexible but it
means that you have to ramp up in
shorter period of time so as long as you
are responsible and you know that you
can do that no problem
okay so I'll take more questions but let
me just ask you guys so why should you
do six you are why should you do super
Europe hmm there are many classes at MIT
yeah many of them that are very
interesting why should you do super your
grad school okay
why super Europe could be useful for
grad school
yeah I mean basically research is
essential if you want to go to grad
school in fact I mean at this stage
people expect that you have some
publication or at least some submission
so if I mean to go to again don't get
scared but I mean basically the more
research background you have as you
apply for grad school the better
position you are in to get accepted and
to get the interest if there is a good
faculty in that department
why else why should you do this
oh yes invent Li this is I was an MIT
student actually I I didn't mind I
didn't do my undergrad here I did my
grad school here and I remember it like
when I was a graduate student I mean
basically MIT students will not stop
talking
she's like ask questions that our main
cases even random questions just keep
talking now you guys are so shy it's
just like question nobody asking any
questions yes the chance to pursue yeah
yeah so yeah so actually honestly the
most important reason to do this is to
try actual research particularly if you
are passionate about something like some
particular field of research to try to
get into it understand it so the way
just to give you an example so you guys
I mean I don't know how many of you have
been engaged in research so far okay so
that's good like a reasonable percentage
of you but if you think about it I mean
MIT what is so special about MIT I mean
the classes are great but really this is
a research university this is a place
where the best and most interesting
research in engineering happens and if
you are spending like four years here
and graduating with a degree whether you
are going to grad school or go into the
industry or starting your own company
whatever it is it's like if you haven't
done research and haven't experienced
that then you miss the whole point when
you miss the the best thing here I mean
yeah you got the classes but that's
really not the whole story that's very
very small part of the story it's like
going to Paris and not seeing the the
fal tower for example it's like
everyone's gonna ask you about this so
it is an opportunity to get exposed to
research some people really love it
after that and they decide they want to
be they want to go to grad school they
want to become researchers very few
people discover no this is not for me
but at least you tried it so the most
important reason is actually to do
research what else you get by taking
this class yes normal Europe perhaps
you're not guarantee that you're going
to get experience in terms like poster
submission right now here whereas this
would be a more guaranteed and that's
track so exactly so I'm eating innocence
I mean for people who did Europe and had
like a very structured and organized
Europe experience I mean you got a lot
of the experience with this research but
what the plus allows you to do is to do
it in a more systematic way and for
people who haven't done it to actually
do it
but basically because not only are doing
research you are also presenting that
research as about like okay tell me
about your research prepare a poster
about your research talk to me about
your research then you you are actually
learning the whole process of doing the
research while you are doing that in the
lab but also how do you present your
research how do you eventually get a
technical paper hopefully out of it and
be an effective researcher both in terms
of doing the actual work and
communicating it to other people and
being paid for okay
although reason to do it
how about the the communication
requirements how many of you have this
communication requirement so you get
done with it so so I mean these are few
reasons right always in the feedback
people are happy about the money so this
is but I don't think that's of course
the most important important which is
the most important reason reason is the
research and being exposed to the
researchers I see the one thing that you
should not miss after four years at MIT
and you get your CLC I am requirement so
other things about the class that are
cool is like it's really even cool for
me as professor at MIT so every lecture
we invite one to two speakers and those
people are MIT faculty so imagine those
people are typically paid I don't know
how like humongous amount of money to
come and give a lecture somewhere but
they come and give you a like each one
of them come to one of those costs to
tell you about their research to tell
you about what they are doing and it is
really a great opportunity that doesn't
happen otherwise and you get to see
research across the whole broad spectrum
of engineering from machine learning the
computer vision to NLP to circuits to
computer systems to networks to
sometimes people in material science in
biology or bioengineering digital health
the whole broad spectrum and yeah you
are in the lab doing one thing focusing
on your problem and your project but it
gives you perspective and breaths across
all of these fields and areas and that's
really I mean as you get to experience
that it actually is a great experience
if you are interested I mean you are all
at MIT science I mean you're all
interested in science and engineering
okay so where to learn more about the
super Europe so you can go to superior
up the mit.edu
and if you want to apply then you apply
a super Europe - applying that mit.edu
and like this is the contact email I
mean if you go to the site you'll find
all the email and the information but
the other thing that I want to end with
is some of the deadlines so that all of
you are aware of them so a poster so as
we said like basically go on the website
try to check for the projects that all
available and you are also free to try
to create your own project as long as
you find some professor who's willing to
supervise that project so April 3 is a
deadline if having intent and saying
that you want to join the super Europe
April 27 is the deadline for submitting
a proposal so as we said you go and talk
to that professor you understand the
project better and then you submit about
one page of description of that project
typically we ask you to have some
figures just to show that you have some
understanding of the project that you're
gonna work on and in June we announced
the funding and who is going to be in
the class do you want to add something
that's included or of recommendations
Maurice you super your supervisor you
don't have to include it you have to ask
your supervisor for recommendation or
just that they accept the students to us
for them they say I'm enthusiastic about
supervising the students I believe they
will be successful in the project they
have yeah so it's not like they don't
have to write like a full water of
recommendations just as they are saying
that they are enthusiastic to work with
you and I have talked to you okay so oh
that's the last slide I have I can
answer two more questions
so the chances are very high which I
like unless we believe that for example
your GPA it's like if the person GPA is
very low and we think that they are
taking too many classes all the GPA
might be high but they are taking too
many classes they don't have time to
spend ten hours in the week and per week
in the laughs then those cases are the
one that gets rejected mostly most
people get accepted so as long as you
are doing reasonably well you are not
overloading yourself we think that you
have reasonable chance of success
succeeding in the class then you get
accepted and the adviser has to of
course agree to supervise you Europe
stuff so the stuff is a collection of
faculty research senior research staff
and so it will be like Europe and Dorsey
has been with the class for an analysis
it started in 2012 so she has do you
have to can she take a screenshot and
does it have to be an official people to
submit their transcript is it okay if
they just take a screenshot is it
unofficial don't spend money I would try
to be flexible as now Objectivists not
to make you go out of your way is there
like a set list of professors that can
be super your office supervisors or can
you get any as long as you like
establish contact
so they have to be there the partner has
to be part of the participate in
Department like there are means giving
it like for example I guess mechanical
engineering is a participating
Department so you can get the professor
there I know there might be some
Department accident know biology
probably is not a participating
department and then you can't just have
somebody in biology if you have somebody
in biology then we ask you to have
someone that's kind of like a shadow
advisor in in WCS you know and you guys
can send emails like if you have
specific questions that are not answered
or you have specific case so please send
email to this account yes highly likely
to get in the third class and then the
next question is whether we have money
into the class means you go to the class
credit you know he has worked hard to
raise money to support drop Steenson
job more optimistic the department to
raises money every year to pay the
students so we don't know ahead of time
how much money it will be able to raise
and therefore how many students in total
we can accept for funding you know
easier students working with easiest
professors that's highly likely to get
funded easiest students working with
aero-astro were Becky professors that's
funded them last year but we had enough
money sure students working with
dialyzer professors he does
well depends whether our bathroom oh
maybe we can't take it I'm just worried
about like there are two more speakers I
can come to the end of the class and
answer your question audio she can
answer your question but I want to allow
this virtual speaker enough time
good afternoon everyone is an MIT wide
initiative on the science engineering
and application of intelligence and this
year we are very happy to offer over 20
super Europe possibilities of founding
and so I'm one of the directors of the
quest and I'm going to give you a brief
overview of the topics but most of the
opportunities related to the quest are
not yet on the website we hope to have
posted all of them next week on the
website so you have kind of a preview
right now so the project come in certain
different type of organization there is
what we call the bridge project so the
quest bridge is a community of research
scientists and software engineers who
are working with undergraduate and
graduate students towards very big and
large project and you have a few title
over here
if you're interested to work with our
students on a topic that is highlighted
here from gaze tracking in a childhood
or greenhouse gas impact very important
face recognition anything related to a
biology like some topics then this might
be something that is good for you so we
have a few on this there is a second
type of super weapon ET that are
actually more tied to brain and
cognitive science development and we
call them the quest science and they
have a nickname scaling AI the human way
and this is an ambitious research
program that is leading by Professor
Josh Tenenbaum and many of a faculty at
MIT and the C cell and at how can we
build and grow and Intel system that
will have some intelligence with
something human and a child so there
will be a few project also on that topic
a further class
for the class of project they are more
computational science and engineering
project those will be faculty driven so
when you go next week to the website and
you see some project you interested in
if you see quest written somewhere quest
for intelligence it will be one of those
founded by us and here you have a three
example that are on a values topic and
we also have a project that are like we
don't put an ad about it but I tell you
about it those will be any faculty or
project you will propose to a faculty
relative to FinTech then we could pick
it up if it's a project that is
interesting in that area so this is sort
of this iver you interested in this
larger topic the finance industry and
many of the machine learning algorithm
that I related to this then you can find
a faculty and come back to us saying hey
I found a faculty have a good idea can
we do something together so those are
more open and we also have some that are
related to the MIT IBM Watson AI lab I'm
also the director of this lab on a
variety of topic you will see the
variety of topic next week and I what I
would like to emphasize today is
certainly for the certainly the the
bridge project the computational
engineering one some of the FinTech and
the MIT IBM if you are interested to go
to industry then those are potentially
sort of project where you will do a
research still at MIT was at an MIT
professor but more aligned to some of
the questions that are interesting in
industry so therefore beyond grad school
those could offer you the possibility to
have also somebody from IBM Co
supervising you but also start touching
some of the question interesting for
industry again most of them will be
online next week thank you
question I shall take all right thank
you
hi so I'm Maddy Wozniak and I was a
superhero op student last year and so
first off does anyone like have any
questions about like my experience
personally because I also have talking
points but if there are any specific
questions I don't know if you did your
ops in the past but did you difference
taking this serious superhero princess
difference between dropping during your
classes yes yeah so I to find my project
there's a list of like superhero
projects and so I just like went on that
site and looked through the projects and
like found some that I was interested in
and then reached out to the supervisors
and met with them and then just like saw
what would be a good match and went with
that and then in terms of your second
question with the UROP I think super
Europe was a lot like more structured
and like focus kind of like how Dina
talked about you have like deliverables
throughout the year that you're actually
like working on and so towards the end
you have like a paper written and also a
poster and so you're like guaranteed to
have that and then also I guess I had
like weekly meetings with my supervisor
and so that really helped like keep the
research going and then also having like
the ten hours a week set was a good way
to like make sure that we were like
constantly working because I know with
your ops it's like not as much pressure
and it would sometimes like sink lower
on my priority list but was superyacht
since there's like a class associated
with it and everything it was like
higher on my priority list yeah there so
the main stuff is the paper and then
there's also the poster but then instead
of like they kind of like split it up
over the course of the semester so I
think you have to write like an
introduction for like one week and then
you move into like methods and then
related work and results and so it's
like split up like week by week so I
think they do a really good job of like
helping you manage your time so it's not
like a scramble at the end of this MS
like put it all together so so we're
looking for a project do you do you just
like find one on the super Europe
website and like reach out that
professor or are you like reaching like
are you reaching out with the intent of
like like I read about your project and
like here's this thing I want to like
spend on it yes yeah so for me it was
they had a proposed project and then I
just like talked to them about it and
like learn more about it and really was
interested in it and so I just went with
that I know you can also like continue
extending a current your app I think you
can also like reach out to professor's
and just like learn more about their
research and see if you want to extend
it to so there's like a bunch of
different options yes
there's posted projects but you can work
dewdrop with anyone and not every
professor most projects go with
professors you've done well with in
their class
any other questions so I guess I can
just like talk a little bit more about
my experience so I the reason that I
want to go into super Europe was because
I was planning to do an image and I
thought that it would be like more
structured and more long-term on than
just a semester-long Europe and so the
main reason was to prepare for that
meant and then I also wanted like the
mentorship in the lab and also the
classroom to improve the research and
communication skills and so my project
was working with Professor Thomas hull
and then I worked with a doctor at Beth
Israel Medical Center named Wendy
Thompson and so my project was on
leveraging clinical data to optimize
oxygen delivery to preterm infants in
the neonatal intensive care unit and so
we were just analyzing different factors
that may be affecting the oxygenation of
preterm infants and then trying to
figure out if we can improve the
clinical workflow to maximize the amount
of time patients spend in their target
oxygen range to prevent mortality and
morbidity and so as I mentioned before
is like a really guided research
experience I thought the weekly meetings
with the professor and the clinician was
really helpful and so if you guys do
super Europe I would recommend like
setting that up because it really like
keeps the research like moving along I
also got a bunch of great opportunities
such as like shadowing the neonatologist
and a nurse at the hospital and just
like learning more about the hospital
workflow and then there were like weekly
lab meetings where we would learn about
like other researchers in the lab and
what research that they're doing and
then I also got to present at that so I
got like feedback on my work and
different ideas that I could incorporate
I also got to present at the New England
perinatal society meeting which was like
a mini conference for neonatologists and
clinicians in the New England area and
so that was a really good experience and
definitely helped with like presentation
practice and just overall is really
great to work on the project and really
like dive deep into it over the course
of the year on the classroom side of
things I thought that six uar was like
really interesting and useful the weekly
lectures with the researchers presenting
their work it was
really cool to see like different
domains across campus and just like stay
up to date on research at MIT and then
there are also TAS and communication
instructors that would provide helpful
feedback for the research paper and also
the poster there were any downside I
know some people have said that some of
the assignments might be like busy work
but like personally I thought that
everything was really useful and like
really helps guide like writing the
paper so yeah I don't know about
downsides yeah yeah off the top of my
head I can't think of anything like
negative about superyacht so is there
ever a time because you're doing
research sometimes research work out
great
what happens then if you've if you're
trying something and it's not working
his seller gets our gate and sometimes
you'll have all these meetings every
week with people and you know you're
good everybody will agree what's
happening hopefully they will have some
other ideas other perhaps University
some people change project between the
balm of the spring but that's pretty
tricky because you I think it was kind
of all the fall work in with the paper
you can have two negative results yeah
right up everything you've dried I mean
that that's really useful too
two other people working in them know
what let me try yeah yeah personally I
didn't have any like major roadblocks
but I know that some people do and I
think if you just like communicate with
your supervisor it'll like all work out
in the end yeah I guess now that I'm
thinking about it like one like kind of
downside was in the fall I think since
you're like ramping up your research
within the first like two weeks there's
already like things do like an
introduction and so it's totally okay to
like not have like your methods like
totally fleshed out yet and just like
having like a starting introduction and
methods it's always like good and so you
don't need to freak out and be like like
I haven't started my research yet like
what am I supposed to be writing like
it's only two weeks in right is there's
TAS and communication instructors that
you work with and so there's like
check-ins with that and they really help
with the writing process and also
putting together the poster and so I
thought those meetings were really
helpful yeah
and so overall like I think it was like
a really good experience and I highly
recommend doing it it's really cool to
just work on your research over the
course of a whole year and then have the
deliverables like the poster and the
paper at the end to like showcase
everything that you did and I got the
poster presentations you also get to
talk to like other people in your field
and they can be interested in your
research and then also like tell you
what they've worked on and it's just
like a really interesting experience so
yeah
so thanks for coming there's wires with
dates for the back there's a short in
the back there's more pizza don't let us
know if you have any questions